oh that wallet wallet love that one
would you like the leather it's the
softest titanium Weaver really yeah yeah
yeah yeah do you have a wallet I do what
do you use my wallet yeah yeah let me
see okay it's a leather it's leather
used to be iron man I used to have an
Iron Man wallet but at war out yeah
pretty new it's pretty nice though huh
yeah keep my ID in here that's it you
really yeah yeah sure what is it well he
thought Dreyfus is a UFO operator's
license it's this alien alien the guard
says under sex under sex it says yes
under sex is here yes hi 3 2 wait 35
hernán eyes black it expired my three
thousand three one in a fantastic every
thousand one it expired well that's
great so you're you can operate a UFO
pretty much yeah can you know I don't
never even been one stick around kid do
you believe in hell yeah brush although
I don't believe in crop circles I have a
theory
what and this is no disrespect but I
think I think people we have what's that
ailment you're a doctor what's the
animal that that kids have which don't
want the kids are like to run around in
circles
[Music]
just in tight circles yeah there's a
hamster all right how old are these kids
no three five three five and they run in
circles yeah they like to watch split
plates spin around and is that autistic
I mean it could be i think we he thinks
you're thinking of autism yeah yeah and
well it's just it's just there sometimes
they're hard just a hand off because
they can be hyper and they're riding
circles and and I have a theory that
that crop circles are the result of
exhausted parents taking their kids to
cornfields late at night their autistic
kids letting them out in the fields and
having them run around and perfectly
geometric circles holy [ __ ] we were
visited last night circles right but
mystery solved guy I never thought of it
that guy here we go here we go right so
what you're saying to me is just let me
get this clear sure is it okay sure
clear enough I will clear I've seen
autistic children right never really
seen them run in a circle but it's fine
okay in fact I'm going to disprove your
theory a lot of times autistic kids
don't even like one of the signs of like
early autism is they don't like the
feeling of grass on their feet yeah but
I said corn autistic kids love love they
do love what they do love never see
children of the corn yeah yeah all those
kids they're autistic for sure yeah
Malakai Malakai without this really
autistic he was the leader joke's on me
maybe you should read more I'm sure
yeah you're right grass is not car do
you think that we've been visited by the
aliens I think it's likely yeah you know
it's you know when you think of the vast
expanse of the universe and the galaxies
and it's hard to believe that there were
the only living speck in the whole you
know whole universe yes it's probably
very likely something else has been here
whether it's been while we've been here
or whether it was 200 million years ago
yeah it's a lot out there guy hey guy
you think that they left
technologies here on earth it's possible
footprints for sure things that probably
aren't very like visible to the naked
eye like things that are either
microscopic her things that are already
part of our soil things that we're not
really looking for because we're looking
for a shaped alien man now that's the
wrong thing to be looking at well what
you're saying though that is our
atmosphere you know things that are we
don't even have the capacity to like
measure but what you're saying then
basically to me baby is is this is that
you think that maybe there's a slight
chance that before there was even life
on this planet that the beginnings we
made from cells what are we made of
sound cells yeah molecules that they
planted that [ __ ] in here and that we
could be descendants from aliens no
that's not what I said at all
I like that zero but I like that I like
that Prometheus but you can you can like
through RNA synthesis that theory you
can recreate it in the lab and that
actually proves how we became like
mammals and things like that RNA to DNA
to life you can recreate that through
thermal vents underwater I know that
everyone knows that's underneath the
[ __ ] water no don't you think yeah
yeah you know about the thermal vents
right who doesn't go right I mean we've
[ __ ] read books about it down low but
do you think that well let me ask you
this though
but they're not you don't think that
they're living amongst us you know it's
hard it who knows that's the thing it's
possible you know I think any anything's
possible because you can't disprove that
they're not living that's right you
can't prove it but you can't disapprove
Jesus then right Jesus
anything the devil I mean we can do it
we can do true we can sort of Fraggles
whatever else you know what a Fraggle is
right yeah well Fraggles we don't have
to disprove because they had their own
TV show oh yeah that's true
Fraggles did have a breath the Fraggle
Rock so we know the living room oh by
the way so it's paid cable I always
thought about you and and and forgive me
for saying this but I always thought
that maybe you could be an alien
interesting I would maybe maybe I am a
you're a weird guy maybe I am you maybe
you are would I tell you if I was I wish
you would okay I am you are go to Arby's
what's it always earth food roast beef
is that our peas Wow we shall go to the
drive-thru mr. Lee Wow you shall have
potato cakes and horsey sauce mr. Lee
say they sound like that's what I sound
like
let's call us they do you plumping you
[Music]